لنترك الملف ملف تصنيف الحرس الثوري
ونتحول الى الجديد في انشطه هذه
الميليشيات الاساسيه بالنسبه لسياسه ايران
الخارجيه فملف المشروع الايراني للدفاع
الجوي في سوريا لم يبح بعد بكل اسراره
فبعد الكشف عن افشال المشروع من طرف
اسرائيل بدات تتسرب معلومات اكثر حول
خبايا هذا المشروعات صحيفه ايران
انترناشونال لبست اكثر في خفايا هذا الملف
لتكشف النقاب عن المزيد من التفاصيل
البدايه بالعقل المدبر للمشروع الايراني
حيث قالت الصحيفه ان داوود جعفري احد قاده
القوات الجويه للحرس الثوري الايراني هو
الذي انشا هذه الشبكه
قبل ان يقتل في ظروف غامضه في سوريا شهر
نوفمبر الماضي في عمليه اتهمت الطهران
اسرائيل بالقيام بها
ذراع الايمن لجعفري لم يكن سوا فريدون
محمود سقي وهو قائد فرقه خاصه في الحرس
الثوري تم تكليفه باداره جزء من المشروع
فان المهمه اسندت لاحد كبار المسؤولين في
الحرس الثوري الايراني ويتعلق الامر بجواد
غافري الذي طرد من سوريا في الخليفه
الماضي
قبل ان يتم تعويضه بمحمد رضا زاهدي احد
قادت فيلق القدس تابعه للحرس الثوري
الايرانيه
اكبر من نقاء وهو ما تطرقت اليه ايران
انترناشونال التي قالت ان الناشطين
لبنانيين من حزب الله كان مقربين من جعفري
عمله في هذا المشروع كما ان عناصر الدفاع
الايرانيه كانت تتلقى المساعده من عملاء
السريين على درايه باستخدام معدات حساسه
للغايه في مجال الدفاع الجوي دون ان ننسى
ان هذا المشروع تم بشكل مشترك مع قوات
النظام السوري
هذا في تمكين زرع نظاما ايرانيا مستقلا
للدفاع الجوي من داخل سوريا
[موسيقى]
ماذا وظفت ايران تحديدا في هذا المشروع
الذي صرفت من اجله عشارات الملايين
سهران وفضلا عن سعيها يا طاهر نحو انشائي
منصه للدفاع الجوي قامت ايضا بمساعده
النظام السوري على تحديث مجموعه من
الرادارات الخاصه به بغرض الكشف عن
الهجمات الاسرائيليه ومنعها بشكل اساسي ضد
المؤسسات الايرانيه في سوريا
صاروخ صياد فوربيا الذي يعمل بالوقود صلب
والذي تم الكشف عنه في نوفمبر الماضي وتم
دمج القذيفه بمنظومه الدفاع الجوي بافار
ثلاثه سبعه ثلاثه والقادره على كشف اهداف
تبعد ب 320 كيلومترا